with armed police surrounding this block
of flats in heighten they led their
first suspect away a 36 year old who
they'd just arrested on suspicion of the
murder of nine-year-old olivia at her
home on monday night
as the police work started at that
address officers were arresting a second
man aged 33 in dovecot close to where
the shooting happened
how cooperative they'll be we don't know
everything points to this shooting being
a gangland dispute that ended
unintentionally at olivia's family home
any death is unfortunate uh on a
strategy but it makes it 100 times worse
that's a young child with a life ahead
of her cecarias used to operate in the
liverpool underworld and is now
rebuilding his life
away from this chaos
if the gang members had gang members who
have got no winfrey whatsoever they
don't like the perpetrator if they don't
like him they'll probably put his name
in to get rid of them
yesterday club legends from liverpool
and everton visited the scene and later
at anfield there will be appeals for
information and in the ninth minute of
the game a minute's applause
whatever we do it will not it will not
help father for the moment will not um
but
anyway you have to you have to try
to to ease the situation slightly if we
can do something we will do it
the detectives on this case and the two
other fatal shooting inquiries in this
city say they will not rest until the
killers
and their accomplices are caught tom
parmenter sky news liverpool